-Thank you for being
such a good sport.
Every time you come on the show,
we do a little dance-off,
and you always crush me.
-That's not true.
-I just love to see
your moves, man.
You know I'm a fan.
-Thank you. It's a blast.
It's a workout, too.
-Trust me --
I just caught my breath.
-Personal training.
-The audience knows, but during
the commercial break,
yeah, they came out with
an oxygen tank, and it was sad.
It was really sad.
-Why do I actually believe it?
-Yeah, it did happen, yeah.
I got to congratulate you,
I think.
Yesterday was your anniversary?
-One of them. So...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Happy anniversary.
With your girlfriend? What...
-Yeah. So, my
girlfriend and I --
You know, Ky asked me to be the
girlfriend on the 8th.
January 8th.
But then, I was like,
"You know what?
I also need to ask
you to be my girlfriend."
So we did that.
-Okay.
-And yesterday was the
anniversary of that day,
when I asked Ky
to be my girlfriend.
We actually celebrate
four days, though --
when Ky asked me
to be girlfriend,
when I asked Ky
when we told each other that
we liked each other,
and when we kissed
for the first time.
-Ah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
We celebrate all four --
8th, 14th, 28th, and 29th.
-Is that exhausting?
-I mean, we're on
month number eight now.
-So it's cute.
-And we'll probably
stop at a year.
I would imagine, every year,
we would only celebrate.
-I notice you're not wearing
your signature hair bow.
My girls wear them all the time.
You have JoJo dolls.
You have your own clothing line.
I mean, it's --
-I got it all.
-Yeah, bud.
-Crazy. It's amazing.
-I'm so happy. Yeah, you do.
You do have it all, yeah.
-It is. It's wild.
It's so awesome.
You know, I'm so thankful
for everything that I have.
Being a brand
is the coolest thing ever.
-Yeah. I think you handle it
so well, too.
-Thank you. I appreciate it.
-I really do, yeah. Respect.
-Thank you. I'm a human brand.
-Yeah, you are.
-So it's fun.
-You are a human brand. Yeah.
But this is even crazier.
They want to rename
Ronald Reagan Airport to
JoJo Siwa
Washington National Airport.
-They do!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at this.
Change.org.
Go to this Website.
-Go petition.
-You're really close.
This might happen.
-When my mom told me,
I was like, "Oh, funny.
Like, ha-ha.
500 petitions, right?"
77,398.
-Yeah.
-That's a lot!
-That is a lot.
If you get to 150,000,
this is going to be --
This is going to happen.
-Is that how that works,
if it actually gets there?
-I don't know how things
work in life,
but I think this is how it does.
-No, it becomes one of the top
signed on the website.
That's cool!
-Yes, of course!
-Yeah!
-When you come on next time,
you'll have your own airport.
-I am going to
have my own airport, yes.
-And you will be the champ on
"Dancing with the Stars."
I'm rooting for you, buddy.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is major.
-Thank you.
-I think you're
going to be great.
-Thank you. I'm so excited.
-Are you nervous?
-Not really.
I told myself after "Dance Moms"
that I was never allowed to be
nervous again,
and I stuck to that, actually,
because I miss out on the fun
if I'm always nervous.
But being in rehearsals,
it is so hard,
and everyone's like,
"Well, you're a dancer,
so you got it, right?"
And I'm like, "Yes,"
but I explain it like
a football player
trying to play baseball.
It's still a sport.
It's just
a really different sport.
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
-And that's how it is.
You know, the styles
I'm trained in for dancing
are very different
than everything ballroom.
But it's so fun.
My partner is a female.
I'm the first-ever
same-sex couple on
"Dancing with the Stars."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-I love that.
-Thank you.
So, it's really cool.
And we're both so comfortable
with the idea.
She's incredible, so talented.
I can't wait!
Monday, Monday, Monday, Monday!
-You did me a solid.
You were one of the first guests
on "The Kids Tonight Show,"
which is going to stream
October 14th on Peacock.
We started a show just for kids,
and you were one of
the first guests.
So thank you for doing that.
-It's the most fun show
ever, no offense.
But it's...
[ Laughter ]
-But they're cute, right?
-They're so fun and cute
and just little,
and they know what
they're talking about
and they're well put-together
and they're creative.
And we played games,
and they whupped me
at all of them.
But they're just awesome.
-I want to talk about
"The J Team."
-Oh, yeah!
-That's me, man.
We're on the J Team together.
-Yeah, you're on the J Team.
-I know! Yeah, "J."
JoJo, Jimmy.
Yeah, we're on the J Team.
-You were the first person
that I told about the J Team,
so, literally, you are.
-I am the original.
I'm the O.G. J.
-O.G. J.
-I'm the O.G. J.
-Yeah, you are.
-The O.G. J.
And let's talk about
"The J Team.
Now, this is on Paramount+
streaming on this.
Tell everyone what it's about.
-So "The J Team" --
I like to explain it as if
it's me, but I'm a completely
normal 14-year-old.
But I still act the same,
dress the same,
I am the same,
but I'm just normal.
I go to my dance studio.
My dance studio gets turned over
to new management.
New management
kicks me off the team.
It's really dramatic.
So I make my own team.
And my own team is made up
of gymnasts and soccer players
and football players
and cheerleaders
and, you know,
people who don't really fit in.
But they can, because you --
Everybody fits in, in a way.
So it's all about
being yourself,
letting nobody change you,
staying true to who you are,
and not giving up
because somebody
tries to make you give up.
-There you go. That's it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love that message.
"The J Team" --
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is JoJo Siwa in
"The J Team."
Take a look.
-Yeah!
-♪ So I'mma be me ♪
♪ I wear my heart on my sleeve ♪
♪ Won't hide, I am who you see ♪
♪ Nobody can change me ♪
♪ Nobody, n-n-nobody, no ♪
♪ Nobody, n-n-nobody, no, no ♪
♪ Nobody, n-n-nobody
can change me ♪
♪ Change me ♪
-Yeah! JoJo Siwa, everybody!
"The J Team"
is streaming now on Paramount+.